I think one of the things that you know
going back to my Heal the Bay days
whenever you had a problem like this
that the key thing always was that the
environmental community would talk to
the affected industry and then figure
out what the right path was and then
you'd go forward and talk to the state
and say this is what hey the
environmental community and the affected
industry whether it's the restaurants or
it's the the fishermen we agree this is
something that we need to do we
recommend A, B and C so on what are you
going to do to actually make this a
reality and I think that's the sort of
that dialogue needs to be restarted.
I wrote an article recently about a style
of restaurant from Nayarít that sells
grilled snook as sort of their specialty
Pescado Zarandeado
and one of the proprietors the sort has
served me you know sea bass done the
same way as the snook, saying that it
was getting sort of harder and harder to
catch. And though you know I've done
whatever seven meals in this thing and I
almost written the piece I started to freak out
a little because I didn't want to
encourage people to eat a fish that was
endangered so I did some reading about
it and some and some research about it
and found out that actually, mostly
because of sport fishing and because
snook is such a treasured
you know sport fish that you're not
allowed to catch it commercially in
Florida and that in the Gulf it's not
doing so well but that along the
Pacific coast it's one of the most
abundant species and it was coming from
the Pacific so I felt you know
encouraged by the IUCN that I could
write about it when I wrote about
Yucatecan place a couple weeks ago they
served empanadas stuffed with cazón and
I'd always thought of cazón as shark
and you're not supposed to eat
shark and I was flipping out about it a
little bit then you know what happens
when you do that you do if you don't
have my brother to call you you do some
research and you find out that cazón
I mean obviously is shark but it's more
commonly known as dogfish and it's by far
far far the most abundant shark species and
is in no danger of disappearing, again
in the area where it's being caught for
this restaurant.  So I think it's
necessary to do for me to do to do my
homework good for people doing my
particular job to do the homework